[Music]  Lord showed up to the Grammys in style  NDS with flats in tow  the singers done to this red tulle gown  by Valentino on her back she shared this  powerful poem in support of the meet to  movement and equality on Instagram she  explained writing quote my version of a  white rose the apocalypse will blossom  an excerpt from the greatest of all time  Jenny Holzer ahead of Sunday's Grammys a  source told et that the singer and only  female album of the Year nominee was not  asked to perform solo like all the males  in that category instead she was asked  to perform as part of a tribute and  declined when album of the year was  announced Bruno Mars won but Lord  applauded the Grammy goes to  24 and despite the Grammy performance  snubbed she remained in good spirits all  night chatting with celebs like jay-z  and Miley Cyrus  [Music]  you